tonight's Gordon Smith lecturer his
Steve Boros
you know vice-president for w w SP USA
and director of buildings for the same
firm w SP affirm i did not know what
about before so i it's it's even
possible to be a dean and wearing
something w SP provides design
environmental and management services to
be built to the built and natural
environment drawing on a staff of over
thirty one thousand five hundred
employees that makes it's bigger than
the entire population of Yale faculty
students and all employees mainly
engineers technicians scientists
architects planners surveyors design
professionals and various environmental
experts
WSP global is based in Montreal Canada
and it's comprised of more than five
hundred additional offices across 39
countries on five continents I'd like to
acknowledge the generosity of Gordon
Smith the distinguished engineer
specializing in building enclosure
systems who has endowed this series mr.
Smith in 1957 graduate of Yale College
is a great friend both to the college
and to this school as is mr. Smith's
custom he is with us in the audience
tonight and is it my pleasure to welcome
him in establishing this lecture series
Gordon Smith intention was to bring to
our school speakers who reflect and
enlighten fragment ISM that is who work
whose work combines the highest level of
technical accomplishment and with
artistic excellence most of the speakers
in the series have been drawn from the
engineering professions as our speakers
tonight
such engineers as York Schlick Robert
Stillman Cecil Beaumont Leslie Robertson
Chris wise Werner sobic Anya bras low
and Hanif Kara have all lectured in the
series as have such architects as Myron
Goltz
and Rafael viñoly in spring 2014 the
Smith lecturer was london-based
architect Jim air Steve Boros is the
28th Smith lecturer mr. Burrowes has
over 30 years of experience and
engineering building around the world he
has worked on all types of buildings
including stadia mixed-use commercial
buildings retail and razor development
hotels and airports currently based in
WSP san francisco office mr. burrows
main many notable projects include the
new headquarters for Apple in Cupertino
California the Beijing Olympic Stadium
better known as - most of us as the
bird's nest Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business and the City
of Manchester Stadium in the United
Kingdom built for the 2002 Commonwealth
Games in 1982 mr. burrows received the
BS a Bachelor of Science honours in
civil engineering from liverpool
polytechnic he is a 2004 recipient of
the Brunel medal and was named a
commander of the Order of the British
Empire in 2009 please join me in
welcoming Steve burrows the 28th Gordon
H Smith lecturer as he delivers the
lecture today is the greatest time in
history to be an engineer
so I just turned this lapel mic on can
you hear me at the back yeah and not in
heads that's the case it's fantastic to
be here I'm gonna do a real Whistlestop
tour through lots of slides so first of
all I'm going to introduce myself
so as Robert said I'm a civil engineer
they see it these are my qualifications
across the top sorry I got it can we
drop the lights on the stage a little
thank you very much that's good so now
you can see my qualifications even
better across the top so I'm a commander
of the British Empire which is an honor
bestowed on me by the Queen but I'm also
a civil engineer you can see fic II
fellow of the institution of civil
engineers and fasc II I'm a fellow of
the American Society of Civil Engineers
and if you look in the yellow pages
under boring it says see civil engineers
so my intention tonight is to try and
not be boring I'd start by telling you a
little bit about myself so this is me in
1966 I think there's a is there a
pointer thing over here oh here I've got
it works here it's fine
so this is me here
I got to yeah my mum says actually this
is I went to a Catholic school and all
the boys had to wear ties they had to
wear the grey shorts you had to wear
this sort of greeny sweater or a blazer
and I wore no tie gray jacket and my mum
said I never really conform to anything
and and I think that's really the been
the story of my life and and I'm going
to try and give her a bit of advice at
the end on what have I learned through
that process by the way 1966 it was a
fantastic year if you're if you're
English because you know we England won
the World Cup in 1966 but much more
importantly than that Eric Cantona was
born who was the best player that's ever
played for Manchester United which is my
team so this is Mike this is my car so I
Drive a DRK great car so it's made in my
hometown the town where I was born and
that's why I bought it and it's a
three-wheeled car as you can see so you
driver sits on the back wheel engine
sits on the front two wheels and anybody
who knows anything about engineering
knows that three-wheeled cars are much
better than four-wheel cars the proof of
which is when a four-wheel car goes
around the corner it always tries to
lift a wheel it just wants to turn
itself into a three-wheeled car so I
save some time and have three wheels
from the beginning so it's a great car
but obviously a bit weird and I'm going
to talk about this so projects I'm going
to give you sort of background on where
I see things are today what of what do I
think of the big macro things that are
affecting designing buildings today and
I'm going to base it around this so you
know every project we do we have this
balanced time cost quality time and
quality going one direction and cost
goes in the other direction I'm really
just going to talk about this I'm just
going to talk about time so my entire
presentation is really about about time
and and both the past and the present
and the future
so let me start so so I have been
fortunate enough throughout my career to
be able to
study some interesting things and and
one of the one of the interesting things
is that I've been able to go and look
back in time so I actually have a TV
show so I've had a series of TV shows
the first one I made was the title the
opening title slide the first show was
called engineering the impossible where
we actually took drawings of Roman
cranes in the Vatican Museum and built
them in the US and we actually lifted a
Ford f-250 truck with three students
inside the wheel was like a big hamster
wheel so we were sort of trying to
replicate how things were built in Egypt
in Rome and the latest show I did was
was this so it was really about oh I'm
going to talk about time so three
periods of history where I think it was
a great time to be an engineer the first
one in Egyptian times and I was lucky
enough to go and sort of laser scan the
pyramids so that was basically the
show's call time scanners that you can
still buy it's been on here and you can
buy it on Amazon or if you're interested
in it but basically the premise of the
show was laser scan and ancient
monuments turn it into a model post
process it using some modern engineering
software and learn something new about
how they might have gone about and done
it so so you know our study in the step
pyramid that's the this is this the
world's first multi-story building so
this was a master by a single story
building I've forgotten other thing
works oh there it is this was a single
story building here and in potap
actually added levels on the building
and in doing so what I discovered was
the understood ground bearing pressure
he understood the the issue of building
a multi-story building and the fact that
there was some basic science there some
basic understanding in building this
building in it's obviously stood the
test of time you know it's been around
six and a half thousand years or so to
date and it's not in bad shape you know
to be honest
so we laser scanned it inside and out
you can see that there was a pretty good
understanding of engineering theories
this is in the burial chamber so they
were stepping the stones back corbelling
to
eight large volumes inside the building
there they understood the ground
conditions they understood how to place
the stones so that it tied together well
it's pretty pretty interesting and and
standing the test of time you know what
it what did I learn from the step
pyramid well they used consistent
materials they use materials that that
the thermal properties of the materials
were very consistent so it stood the
test of time because one of the things I
hate the most about constriction today
and apologies to anybody who who
involved in these things is that sticky
stuff that goes in joints because that
allows people to build badly and what
they couldn't do at this time was build
badly if they wanted longevity so you
know it's pretty interesting
they built well I mean they the the
Great Pyramid we scanned
inside and out I mean the idea of the
this part of the show was to to look at
four different pyramids and to see how
the Egyptians learned from one pyramids
or the other so another great thing they
had was a sort of apprenticeship system
so people learned their trade it was
passed down in families over these
pyramids were built in a period of you
know hundred years or so not much more
than that and they actually pass
knowledge down from one pyramid to the
next and you could see by scanning them
and putting them together we could
actually see like this this these are
the laser scans of the four pyramids
that we looked at and we can look at
them in great details these scans are
accurate to a millimeter you could
actually see how they pass knowledge
from one project to the next and this is
an archaeologist from the pyramids who
you know was continually amazed by what
we found because we're using modern
technology on ancient buildings you can
always discover something new so you
know pyramids were the first time I
think if I was born in Egypt times I
would have loved that conversation with
the Pharaoh where he said you know I'd
like you to build me a pyramid and I'd
like you to build me the tallest
building on earth and to make it the
tallest building on earth for about four
and a half thousand years
because that's what he did imagine that
as a brief from a client today it would
be engineering the impossible right but
they did it I mean they did it this is
the timeline and this is this is the
Great Pyramid around here you know not
absolutely sure the dates it's that far
back in history but it was the tallest
building on earth until I think Lincoln
Cathedral was the first building that
exceeded the height of the Great Pyramid
but for a long time something in the
order of four thousand years it's that
as the greatest building on earth and I
know that one of the recent speakers was
talking about about this project but you
know how long will that stand as the
tallest building on earth it will be a
matter of five years maybe you know
something of that order of magnitude
before it's exceeded so it's a pretty
amazing a pretty and made amazing thing
to have built something that lasts as
the tallest building on earth for that
time and you can imagine they were
exploring the limits of engineering so
nobody had ever done this before you
know how did they decide how big to
build they had a schedule they had time
to build with it in the Pharaohs
lifetime and then where they were
cutting and placing stones they had to
determine the height they had the ground
bearing pressure to work with and they
did it and it stood there it's still you
know an amazing structure today I
thought think the second period in
history where it was a great time to be
an engineer was in a time of the Roman
Empire so this guy you know I mean a
pretty interest in this guy
Apollodorus of Damascus my favorite
building on earth the Pantheon I mean
I'm sure there are places better than
that that I haven't yet been to but so
far the greatest place that I've been I
actually had the the privilege of being
inside the pantheon by myself just with
a cameraman being recorded inside but
but mathematically perfect you know
there you're the idea of the building a
perfect sphere fits inside the building
and they really were exploring the
limits of engineering so they created
this huge roof with but the no ability
of the structure to carry tension so
everything was in compression so they
what they did is they they made the
concrete lighter towards the center so
where it needed to be strong and heavy
at the springing points
and towards the sensor they were using
ash to lighten the concrete to make it
thinner and then they applied load on
the outside to counteract the tensile
forces that were developing in the roof
I mean pretty amazing and and and you
know it I mean against from the outside
doesn't doesn't look an amazing building
but you know there's lots of hidden
engineering inside the way they carry
that thrust down to the ground with
hidden walls is pretty incredible and we
we have looked at this building
I've been up right at the outside and a
cherry picker looking really close there
are virtually no cracks in the building
I mean it's hard to imagine I tried to
predict where it would crack and that
would be the beginning of failure you
know the crack will allow water ingress
the you know there will be a point at
which the water freezes that will open
up the crack and it will be sort of
gradual deterioration of the structure
nature always wins in the end but it's
really fighting nature very well there's
almost no cracks on the outside of that
building and yet in a total inability to
carry tension quite incredible these are
some shots from inside and you know I
just love the idea of the way light
comes into the space it's just for me
perfect pretty well in every regard it
was preceded by this this is this is a
dome at Baia so which is just north of
naples and this is this they're you know
still obviously exists and this was
actually an early idea to try and create
something roughly the same scale as the
Pantheon but what they did is because
they were aware that there were these
huge thrusts coming off there off the
after sphere they built it into a
hillside so they actually used the earth
to sort of counteract the forces and so
in the background there you can see the
hill that it was built into and then all
this stuff around here was sort of
butcher Singh to resist that force as
the as the dome tried to flatten out so
you know they were they were testing on
a huge scale practicing for the real
thing and the pumpkin is there is the
real thing
I'm also absolute stadium fanatic I'm
going to talk a little bit about my work
not just the bird's nest but I love
stadiums you know I love them when
they're empty and I did in this show we
also explored the Coliseum and authority
was
interesting to sort of just tell you
what we did so this is Dallas Campbell
who's a TV presenter so they had to put
somebody on TV who looked good and knew
what they were doing alongside me and
that was him and and and we had a you
know really good look we scanned the
Coliseum from the air so this is what we
did we carrot we attached laser scanners
onto the skids of a helicopter flew over
the flew over the Colosseum and then
late digitally scanned it from the air
and and that's on the TV show and it's
pretty difficult imagine how you film
that just an example how difficult it is
this is the sound month so he had to be
in the helicopter with us but he
couldn't be seen so we've got a
cameraman the pilot a cameraman me and
Dallas China it's effectively scan it so
the cameraman is filming us in the
helicopter and the Sandman's hidden down
behind the seats trying to record what
we're saying it was pretty pretty weird
but we did we flew over it we scanned it
from the air and then what we did is we
recreated this Coliseum completely
digitally and then we did a fire exit
analysis from the building so we put an
avatar in every single seat they're
given artificial intelligence and they
can decide how they get which fire
escapes they choose so just like people
when they're in a line they did some
people will wait and some people are
impatient and will change lines and we
compared it to the bird's nest stadium
so we looked at an evacuation analysis
comparison Colosseum versus the bird's
nest the Colosseum one Romans understood
fire exit analysis no question about it
that's not by accident we also had a
look at how is believe that there was a
roof over the Colosseum the Roman
Emperor was actually shaded and we sort
of tried to say we were told sailors put
the shades up so you know we rented a
yacht actually the TV company at this
point thought I'd gone nuts because I
had this idea let's rent a yacht and see
how hard it is to raise a sail and they
were like added onto a helicopter and
now he's on a yacht you know he thinks
he's James Bond but but we did we and it
was really hard work on the yacht and
you know we we had you know it was a
tough job but what we did is we got
Dallas here to raise a sailor just to
see how hard it was to winch up
a single sale and then we use the size
of that sale we did a we basically
looked at some path analysis of the
Coliseum look we know where the where
the Emperor sat we looked we took a
single sale and we just moved it around
until we shaded that spot so we knew
that that in that zone must have been
where the sale was and then we saw how
many people could you reasonably shade
if you did a series of sales and we we
think I think that the actual shading
was not at the top of the Colosseum it
was actually somewhere mid point halfway
down so so that's a bit of history those
two times Egyptian and Roman times and I
believe today is the third time it's the
third greatest period in history to be
an engineer so so why so first of all
the construction industry today and I'm
going to apologize a bit before I do
this because I've caricatured it a bit
right so I'm exaggerating a bit for
effect but hopefully it'll provoke you
into into a response so construction
industry today so imagine when the
pyramids were done when the Colosseum
was doing when the Pantheon was done
there was one mind the the the the
architect architect engineer builder was
one person you know I like you know I in
credit I admire isambard kingdom brunel
but it was that single mind here he
controlled his projects from from the
idea through to the execution of
everything and we've lost that today in
construction we have this as a typical
chart where these are separate contracts
so everybody reports to someone else the
client has different contracts with
different people how on earth could you
apply that process to building a pyramid
you'd have no chance at all but this is
what we do today and we also have we've
we have been well we don't really we
have the ability to do 3d modeling and
and we dream of this the sort of idea
that there is a single there's a single
truth that both the designers and the
contractors use to to develop everything
on the project but there isn't this is
how it works in practice this is what it
really looks like there's data are
passing between different people all the
time and there is no single truth so why
do mistakes get
or just look at that on the right how
could you possibly deliver a project
with a communication process like that
and get a project right there's you know
the construction industry hasn't changed
much over that our our time so I'm not
quite a hundred years old but but this
is a hundred years ago and I just did a
series of slides which I'll click
through quickly and put a shot from that
time of a building being built next to a
car from that time and just as a sort of
visual comparison of how the
construction industry is developed
versus how the motor industry has
developed so that's what you know that
that slide that picture of the
construction for me could be now I mean
there's not much different you still see
these climbing cranes at the outside
they've got a concrete building you see
formwork and props in the way and you
can see the sequence of things being
sort of built and and enclosed as the
buildings being constructed you know I
can see that in many many projects today
if you go on 1930 so Steel's come come
in to be and this is that famous Empire
State Building shot you see the vehicles
changed a bit you know it's got a bit
slicker and white-walled tires and but
but we're still building steel buildings
much the same way stick systems you know
bolts instead of rivets it's still the
process is much the same lift up the
pieces make them in a factory lift them
up fit them together it's a very similar
similar process my thing stadiums this
is a building a seating bowl on the
ground or elevated you know yes we use
precast concrete a lot more but if it's
on the ground it would still look very
much like this we'd be trying to pour
concrete on a slope wet concrete that
slumps on a slope how stupid an idea is
that but but we do and we try and it
struggles and we tamp it in place and
people vibrate it and the cars come on a
bit now it's got you know it's a
retractable roof on this car for
convertible so you know that's getting
better but 1958 was the year I was born
so that's why I use that
as a marker and 1966 the Eric Cantona
was born and this was around the time of
this building this is you know that sort
of era and precast concrete started to
become people said why are we doing all
these things on site why don't we make
the bits and pieces in a factory and
just put them together on site and so
they did everywhere and these sort of
precast concrete buildings emerged all
over the world or mostly in the Western
world and and of course they hadn't got
good enough stuff to stick in the joints
so they leaked and failed and it was the
joints that failed not the precast
concrete but precast concrete got a
really bad name and so people stopped
doing it like that and went back to the
old ways and the cars it looks a bit
slicker now but still looks old right
and then today and I picked this project
I think this is the Met Office
headquarters in Exeter which is one of
my projects actually where we actually
decided to build a building with no wet
trades so we built a building without
any wet concrete placed on site any any
mortar anything that had water in it
because water you know what we do when
we build buildings we put water in the
stuff that has to set and then we spend
a lot of time trying to get rid of the
water afterwards and we don't do a very
good job of it and it's that water the
moisture that stays in the building's
that causes a lot of damage over
certainly the early life and it
restricts the life of the buildings it
restricts the time that the building
will survive cars come on a lot right so
I really would like that car but
completely different also construction
industry old slide but productivity in
the construction industry is currently
at or about the same level of
productivity as it was just at the end
of the Second World War and we're the
only industry in the world that could
has that sad fact every never other
industry productivities improve greatly
but not in the construction industry and
also deaths on construction sites you
know these are it's the worst place next
mining is actually the world
but for obvious reasons but next to it
construction is the place to go if you
want to look for the highest number of
deaths are any in industry something to
be absolutely you know not proud of it
it's very it's very sad that that is the
case so you know manufacturing is a
safer place to be than a construction
site and you only have to walk past one
to see why stuff being moved overhead
all the time you know the rate at which
people are building there are lots of
reasons why construction is not safe and
and of course the industry has this
reputation so you know there are studies
that show 50 percent of labor costs on a
construction site are inefficient i
somebody isn't actually doing something
that makes progress i mean that's
incredible number half the time and
again walk around walk down a you know
any road where others road works and all
you see all you ever see is somebody
standing around right that's that that's
that inefficient time and projects
although there you know in lots of areas
have been dramatic improvement over this
statistic but for a long time projects
out turn cost of projects were in the
order of thirty-five percent above the
tender return price and that's because
the mechanism by which we we buy these
projects is we ask somebody to give us
the cheapest possible price and then and
so we're always going with the person
who has missed something and hasn't got
the price right and they're trying to
make it up through changes and so this
that idea of the that you know the the
original contract is the is the
inflatable dinghy and the yacht is the
change order you know is the sort of
visual of of the construction industry
and like I said you know I'm caricature
in this for effect but you know it's not
good I mean it's not an industry in
which we're proud of the process and the
product on on it on a repeatable basis
and so you know I'm saying that things
have to change if you if you're a design
professional if you're an architect or
an engineer you know life these days
looks a bit like this you know this is
our problem so you know we our fees are
under incredible pressure expectations
are much higher
timeframes for designing a much shorter
people are working longer hours so you
know life can look like this you know
here's you just can't you know you can't
go any more your boss is telling you to
move the load your workload just keeps
getting piled on and the client can't
understand why you're not making
progress
it is tough it's a tough time in the
industry and I think we all recognize
that it's a time that that's that's
going to change so things are not going
to be the same going forward so how will
the future play out having completely
depressed you saying the Egyptians and
the Romans are better than us you know I
thought I like this this quote which
you've all heard before and I thought
you know I'd apply it to a bit of a look
at the future so let me see what tell
you what I think is going to happen so
first of all there's a lot of future
predictions there are things that that
we can predict with some accuracy and
there are lots of things that we can't
predict with any accuracy whatsoever so
you know this is a famous slide from
from 1992 looking at you know what's
going to happen with peak oil you know
it's the population going to continue to
grow or will it be a pandemic and it
will wipe out you know large portions of
the population will will land get scarce
with the population growth and so
there'll be a food crisis you know
natural resources getting depleted
factory pollution you know damaging air
quality very hard that you could draw
any lines on this very hard to predict
but there are some things that we know
so this is the this is the history of
the earth right right from right from
the beginning so there's the formation
of the earth and and here it goes
through through time and we know that
when impo Thep was doing the step
pyramid and he the first use of columns
were made by the Egyptians we know we're
in this period of time now the Holocene
interglacial period started about about
12,000 years ago I mean you know I'm
doing a bit in the scale of this 12,000
you know is about that because the scale
is so massive and and and so what what
do we know we in in that in that era
we're in this epoch the Anthropocene
epoch and
so here's the history of the earth again
up here and these are some things these
are just slides taken from from places
around the world so what is this epoch
this time that we are in started they
believed to started about the time of
the first nuclear explosion on earth is
the first period in the history of this
planet where humans are able to adapt
the planet to us throughout the rest of
the history of this planet we simply
adapted ourselves to the planet but now
we can do all sorts of things we can
flood valleys we can build huge you know
cities like what our if we call that a
city we can we can build you know
buildings over large amounts of land we
can decide to convert places into food
we can get rid of rivers and divert them
and you know we can actually change the
world
for the first time in the history of
this planet that is what this period
this epoch is about and and that is
happening
will that ever reverse I doubt it so for
the rest of this the history of this
planet the less rest of the history of
humankind we will be doing this for the
first time ever it's only 50 60 years
ago that this a disability happened and
of course our planet this is a very
precious thing so this is this is this
is the earth to scale and this is the
drinking water this is potable water to
the same scale in a globe that's
available on the planet Earth and the
same this is the breathable atmosphere
available to the planet Earth so it's
very fragile so we you all know we're in
a period where you know we have the
ability to determine the future of this
planet and yet you know what the
decisions we make are based around very
fragile things we know that temperatures
are rising you know we can you know that
we can I'll give you why and human
contribution to that but the facts are
that temperatures are rising and we've
got to deal with it we also know these
things I think this is a really
important thing we know that this was
you know pretty well I born
was born in 1958 so look you know look
at this that people it life expectancy
so in Latin America and the Caribbean
when I was born was 52 average if I was
there I'd be dead probably average wise
but today look where it is I mean you
know the numbers 18 it's huge
I look at the change you know the change
in more developed regions well I was
brought up in a very poor area of the UK
so you know I might think I actually
think I'm probably I was probably closer
to Latin America and I was to Western
Europe honestly so but my life would
have been you know in that sort of
period of time and now it's up here so
so people are going to live much longer
and the people who are living longer
this is a sort of graph that shows these
are these are women females appear males
across here and this is this as a sort
of the the neutral line of age 45 degree
and and you can see that the women are
living with living much longer in Japan
the men and and but about the same time
you know in Afghanistan so you can see
there's a massive distribution pretty
hard to read how that distribution takes
place on the earth but it actually looks
something like this so this is life
expectancy by color so North America you
can see you got a pretty good chunks in
North America of live in into your 80s
pretty good chunks pretty good chance in
much of Western Europe good chance in
Australia okay in Japan and you can see
you know in Africa you know not so great
and so that's a go at global life
expectancy overall put on the same graph
this is this is the world's richest 1%
so this is the 1% everybody talks about
this is where they live hey guess what
same place they live in North America
Western Europe China interesting and and
Australia so so what why are the 1%
important well they're your clients I I
you know my entire career
I work for the richest 1% and most of
the projects I you know I would ask ya
you know question maybe you can answer
at the end if anybody has worked for
anybody who's in the other 99% as a
client but I bet they're a very few so
these are our clients and that's where
they live and they live a long time and
this is what's happening with the earth
we've seen this before so again you know
1900 we had about 8 hectares of land for
every person on the planet today it's
about 2 and the prediction is that we'll
be you know one and a half or so by by
something that approaches the end of
your career so land is going to get more
scarce and that's going to cause food
water you know
taller buildings denser urban
environments all sorts of issues that
are going to flow from that with an
aging population you know that is what
you're going to be designing with so I
love this slide this is a this is
actually the album cover to super
Trump's 1970s album of the name crisis
what crisis but it's sort of for me sort
of describes it the the you know where
we you know we're happily living in this
sort of planet damaging situation where
you know we want to talk sustainability
but we haven't quite figured out even
what it means or how we're going to
actually implement it but everything's
changing so what's changing what's the
future look like first of all this you
know exponential change is happening
exponential is this you know every year
you get this huge increase in the way
things happen so technology is the most
obvious one but it's happening in lots
of different spaces it's happening in in
medicine so you know the we can now
imagine that that we can cure ourselves
of disease without operations we can
imagine that it will happen there will
be a big somebody will be able to change
our genetic code what will that mean
people will live even longer and I know
they'll be fitter for longer but they'll
also live longer so that trend is going
to increase
X
naturally life expectancy is going to go
up even more and we can do these things
now so that this lady is is eating
chocolate by thinking about it and she's
able to this machine is able to take the
brain impulse and convert it into
movement and and I I believe that what
is happening with technology is this
that you know traditionally we said that
the if there are architects and
engineers the architects focus on this
side of the brain and the engineers
focus on their you know people like me
they understand the math we now to do it
we're rigorous we get you know accurate
you know precise but no flair right and
now I think technology is actually
living in this space so technology is
allowing the two sides of the brain to
become connected and I think for me that
is overwhelmingly what is happening and
it's happening at a huge rate and and
just imagine what that means when when
and I I've been working on a project
which is with a startup company where
they want to allow engineer architects
to do their own engineering using
software without any engineer presence
so that they can play with it for a
while before an engineer gets involved
and so far our software can get pretty
close to DD for structural engineering
and you know definitely beyond schematic
for mechanical engineering without any
engineering involvement just with an
architect putting in the parameters that
he wants to achieve in a building and
the reverse could easily be treated - so
the brains being connected don't know I
like this is my wife or my young my
eldest son Adam and they went to see
David Hockney exhibition at the de Young
Museum in San Francisco and David
Hockney has actually been doing art on
an iPad and what he had produced was
mind-blowing and this combination of art
and technology that the scale and and
and and and sort of range of what he was
able to do was incredible and that sort
of also led me to believe that that this
is possible this connection of the brain
is what's going on at the moment
and I also thought this was interesting
this is a
this 30 I can't remember I stole this
from but I believe that 3d printing is
going to revolutionize the construction
industry completely well it will be like
when I was an engineer early days and
the fax machine came in it was like oh
my gosh this is incredible we can send a
letter immediately and rather than the
mail and an email came along and it got
even faster and this is what's causing
this overload this donkey in the air
issue that everything is wanted
yesterday and but but but so this is the
study 3d printing going to change
everything but this is an interesting
study females versus males and and what
it is here is with with the advent of 3d
printing how do people see themselves so
it's funny that in the US and in Mexico
and China and there's just these three
examples that are taken here you know
basically if you look at this
females associate themselves with the
sort of softer side of things the right
brained things and males with the left
brain things so you know artists vs.
scientists but in China and China is a
billion people that is just not true
that is that the difference is just
these are people just people being
interviewed over social media about how
they perceive themselves but that is a
cultural thing that's embedded in us
it's certainly not embedded in in people
who were born in China
and so with the advent of 3d printing
and the ability of more female engineers
certainly to come from from China I
think that you know we're gonna see a
lot of projects in in the Asia over the
coming years we're gonna see a change in
how things are done I believe it's going
to be completely different I also am a
sort of really I'm a real biomimicry fan
I don't think I quite understand what it
means I'm really struggling to really
understand what I can do with nature
better but I definitely am sort of into
it you know I believe that you know
nature is the Superman thing and and you
know there are some good things this is
obviously the you know the purrs you
know and velcro well you know yeah
you're on it works it's a good idea
and maybe maybe one thing led to another
and yeah recently I saw a number of
things there's been a number of things
being done about nano technologies and
micro scale things and I saw that there
there the ability now is to connect a
sensor to a cockroach yeah and they can
when there's a building that collapses
they send in the cockroaches who
actually find their way through the gaps
in these buildings and by sensors they
can actually find detect people so this
business of taps apps app is there
anybody there they were like they can
actually locate people using the
cockroaches so you can be saved by a
cockroach and a nun swarming is
something else that's being studied a
lot in in science you know how can you a
bit like when I started when finite
element analysis was studied at school I
suddenly felt it was an incredible
breakthrough that by breaking a problem
down into tiny little pieces and certain
boundary conditions and a certain
analyzing the pieces you could suddenly
solve something that you couldn't solve
as a whole well that's happening now on
a biomimicry scale where we're you know
this the idea of flocking and the idea
of swarming is is able to help us solve
problems that we couldn't solve before
and the old classic which is this
they're naturally ventilated buildings
they are supposed to have been informed
by
termite mounds I actually think the
reverse is true I think we design
naturally ventilated buildings and look
round for something in nature that looks
something like it but there's no doubt
that they are very similar that we can
get cooler buildings without any any
energy being put into the system by
following this sort of model I like this
this was a story that I'd read that
there was I think it's in Washington DC
and what had happened was there was this
guy at a company that was spraying
pesticides on plants that were invasive
plants and he started to find that the
plants were getting more and more
resistant to the pesticide and they
weren't just weren't killing them and he
was basically couldn't think of any way
to avoid going out of business and so
what he invented was the goat and he
realized that the goats would eat the
plants and the plants never got
resistant
the goat and so he's now turned his
business from instead of spraying
pesticides he has a hoarder whatever
what is a what is a group of goats
called
what's a collective thing for goats
anyone anything there you go
a faculty of goats it must be true he
said it their faculty of goats that eat
the plants so you're good so this is
what I think is happening you know we're
going way beyond lead you know we're
going from you know all these things
that we've got all these things now
where we talk about you know NetZero
engineer buildings and and Living
Building Challenge and all these things
but I believe it's going towards sort of
much more natural systems in buildings
so what so there's my introduction I
didn't take long did it
there's my introduction and so I'm gonna
say what does this all mean for building
design according to Steve burrows the
engineer so first of all some things
will never change you know I really love
this fourth bridge in Scotland and this
is explained in the structural system I
mean just just great you know I love
these things but you know gravity or
gravity won't go away we got it where
we're sort of stuck with that for a
while and the design process will always
be something like this you know blank
sheet of paper some ideas and then
develop the you know develop up the
ideas so some things aren't going to
change and you know the mathematics of
doing these things isn't going to change
how we do it will at school I learnt to
do calculations using scale rule I've
still got one I don't use it very much
but I've still got one and then we had a
revolution 1973 the calculator came
along and just completely changed how we
do things and we still really were just
using computers presently as really fast
calculators but we're on the verge of a
breakthrough where we can actually do a
lot more a lot of those ideas of
swarming and looking option earring and
doing things differently as I'll talk
about a little bit later there physics
you know this is the buckling equation
which I'm sure you're all very familiar
with and
you know that's a you know it is how we
design columns every column in the world
designed to the same formula and those
because that's how they behave you know
we've done enough testing to know how
columns behave so those things will be
the same but some things have changed I
thought what I do quickly is is a bill
Baker setting it careers defined by five
slide five projects I think of something
I hope it's more than that because I've
chosen to show you quick five projects
and said well however I applied my
engineering knowledge and what I think
to a few buildings and what can we learn
so so visceral this is us this is a book
was given to me by a CEREC Aetna is a
material scientist I did a project with
her and she gave me a book she knows I'm
into stadiums and in the book was this
photograph
Mexico City 1986 these people had built
her own stadium they're watching a
screen outside watching the game and
they cover it and it was raining so they
just created a stadium and I really love
the idea you know stadiums are so simple
things and I wanted to sort of explore
the idea of stadium so this project this
was worth them when I was at Arab so I
was a project director for this for both
the architecture and the engineering
forgive me and and and the stadium was
for the Commonwealth Games in 2002 and
then later for Manchester City Football
Club and that's how good an engineer I
am because as a Manchester United fan I
was responsible for Manchester City
Stadium and that is impressive attire
and so stadium stadiums right you're the
few things you need to know about
stadiums well this is this is a pretty
impressive 148 thousand seats this is a
outdoor running track a Sports Centre
I've got squash courts and things inside
the inside the Sports Centre it's called
Sports City so it's part of a master
plan developed by a door with the
stadium as part of it and and stadiums I
you know I came to learn stadiums are
all based on mathematics so these are
the seats and they look pretty simple
but but you have to figure out how they
work so it's all based on sight lines so
the quality of view in a stadium is
based on this C value which is how good
the line of that you'll the point you're
looking to the nearest point of the
field
how far it is above the person's head
above c60 means it's 60 millimeters
above these idealize people that's how
they measure sight lines and and so you
know there's a mathematical formula for
every seat in the stadium and there's
some some differences so if people are
in wheelchairs are obviously changes the
form your a little bit and you allow for
about 1% of the population
to be in wheelchairs and you have to
design for cameras and things like that
but basically the mathematical formula
for a stadium is determined by maths and
so what we did for this stadium is we
studied to look for the first time at
parametric tools so that as the
architect who develops the bowl changes
the geometry as these things change the
structural design changes automatically
so the architect can start playing
options with the structure so you know
it's interesting we thought we thought
about it this and and what we also did
is we realized that athletic so you can
see the athletics track is about twice
the size of a soccer field and so we
designed a two-tier stadium with an
athletics track in it and a three-tier
stadium with a soccer field in it and
what they did is they built this one
first this one on the Left first and
then we put the bowl underneath and then
they dug it out afterwards and converted
it to a soccer stadium so it works like
this this was athletics so you can see
two tiers on the side a huge athletics
track and then when it gets converted to
soccer three tiers on each side and the
field in the middle so the Athletics
track was at that level when it held the
Commonwealth Games and by playing with
the maths we could get the geometry to
perfectly work with the two different
things which hadn't been done before and
on this Stadium we'd started playing a
lot with things that hadn't been done
before so we liked the idea of a light
roof so this roof is supported by these
external drums as so there's a mass a
compression element here with cable
supporting the roof and we actually got
the roofs so light that the big design
problem was it it went up in the air we
had uplift problems so we created like a
an aeroplane wing and it started to blow
in the air and we actually had to put a
cable right across the roof and see you
can probably see that profile see these
things out here do you trust about see
them those are the tie-down cables to
hold the roof down and we had to put
concrete inside the steel and wait the
roof because the roof was so light so
we're right at the extremes of of what
we could do you know normally these
stadium rooms are incredibly heavy and
we made one that was incredibly light we
also started looking at some of these
other things we went to Cardiff Stadium
where they have sprinklers down all the
concourses and we were in a big crowd
and people were taking their cigarette
lighters and lighting the sprinkler
heads I'm sitting the water off because
they thought it was funny and we said
well we're not gonna I'm not gonna have
that so we want to design a concourse
with no sprinklers so how do we do that
and what we came up with the idea was
the food concessions were like and
collect localized places like this where
the fire started that buying clothes in
the by putting shutters down so that we
can extract the smoke through the top we
extended the toilet extract fans put
them into the concessions reverse them
fire rated the ducts and fans and got
rid of all the sprinklers in the
concourse so this is a stadium with no
sprinklers in the concourse I don't
think that's been done before so there
were a number of things that were you
know real advances another one was
Manchester it rains all the time
that's what Manchester's known for so
because we got this saddle-shaped roof
we put two rainwater pipes on the whole
stadium wanna each end at the low point
of the saddle and we stop the rain water
pipes before a big shaft we put in the
ground source when it rains it's like a
waterfall at both ends of the stadium
you can see it here at night let's see
the rainwater pipe that and it just goes
into a shaft in the ground these are
absolutely huge but we made a feature of
the rain going down the rain water pipes
and then finally these drums on the
outside of the building have the ramps
that take people up to their seats but
in the center drum we put it all the
bathrooms or the machine rooms
everything that we could take out of the
stadium we put in the center of this so
it's serving several purposes it's the
thing that holds the roof up it's the
thing that gets people up inside the
drum our rooms that take all the
equipment for the building
and so inside the building it's really
clean and efficient so it was an
interesting design probably pushed a bit
to the limit technologically but it
shows what's possible after that did
this project with Hertzog de Morin and
Arab so we were responsible for the
engineering and the bowl geometry for
the building and this was an interest in
brief so we Hertzog was certainly
interested in exploring ET Fe as a
material and the brief of the project
was that the project was for two teams
Bayern Munich and TSV 1860 they're the
two teams in Munich and it was going to
be hold the opening game for the World
Cup in 2006 so and they wanted each team
that it was a design and build
competition each team perhaps him have
it feel like it was their own stadium so
I think there were three or four bidders
for the project and most of them did two
entrances to everything so that there
was a Bayern Munich side a TSV 1860 side
but we thought to win this we've really
designed and build so costly is probably
going to be big deal how can we build
less and so we came up with this idea of
instead of having two of everything why
not just change the color of the
building depending on the team that
played in it so the idea was this the
the whole building was clad in ET Fe and
you know if it's a neutral team playing
in it they could be white if it's TSV
1860 it can be blue by a munich it could
be red and even if the national team are
playing in it it can be a multitude of
colours and this was what was built and
you know it's pretty simple structural
solution it's concrete Bowl steel
cantilever roof but exploring et Fe as a
material we were look we were into this
sort of idea of lighter-than-air
materials the competition brief actually
asked for a retractable roof and we
thought no matter what we did they
couldn't build a retractable roof on the
stadium and so we said how can we build
a retractable roof that you don't build
now but you could do later and you don't
penalize the first phase construction
with the weight of a structure that can
support a roof so how do we design a
roof
that's lighter than air so that you know
the idea was could we design a balloon
roof for a 60,000 see a stadium and so
we spent a bit of time sort of exploring
that idea and and you know these are
some things these are real things these
are inflatable structures these are air
beams and there's some you know it's
pretty big space but 60,000 seat stadium
is a whole different scale so we had to
look at that compress there in beams and
what was possible and you can get you
could definitely cover a tennis court
so whether with a structure like this
which weighs you know almost nothing and
you could deploy it when you wanted it
but you couldn't cover a stadium so what
we came up was was this so this was we
actually worked with the original the
original Zeppelin company is still in
existence and we went with them and we
came up with the idea of building these
Zeppelin's this is the parking structure
for Allianz Arena the idea is we tether
it and then we would move it about
quarter of a mile over the stadium when
we wanted to cover it so all it was was
like a deployed envelope a deployed
umbrella that covered the stadium when
it needed to and and you know people
when we did the competition submission
the client said no that's crazy you know
you can't do anything like that but we
were showing this we're saying well
people have already done it so here's my
pyramid again and these are you know old
airships which you all recognize but
these are modern airships this is the
size of these things and we say no these
really exist they all already exist
today and so you know maybe at some
point in the future Allianz Arena will
have a balloon roof
but not today bird's nest stadium well
first of all it wasn't the bird's nest
you know I was there when we were
designing the competition entry with AI
weiwei
and with Pierre de Mar on was was
involved in the team Harry Google's
project architect and the idea was that
it was Ling be stone so we were really
following that this was our idea that we
were told that the grand fathers
polished stones for their grandchildren
set them in a wooden plinth and gave it
to them when they graduated from school
and we wanted to replicate this idea of
a podium a plinth and then as something
that felt natural on top so random line
and really that was the idea that we
were exploring the mayor of Beijing saw
our blind competition entry and dubbed
it the bird's nest and that was the end
of that it was now the bird's nest
stadium and here it is so this is the
Water Cube this is the list of the birds
and I say aerial shot Sasaki did their
master plan for the site absolutely
incredible sites worked it worked
wonderfully well for the Olympic Games
this is the the idea of the buildings I
mean that both design teams were working
at the same time and really you know
trying to find a way to to work off each
other that you know this is a box of
water and box of bubbles and the stadium
is just massive and you know it's just
so is this idea of sort of you know
masculine feminine and and you know
poetic versus exciting
we designed her I mean if we had if we
could do this again today it would be
different so 3d printing would help us a
lot but we were having to model all
sorts of things on this project you can
imagine it's pretty complex this is our
bid book our competition bid book and
these are some other models that we made
as part of the bid this is her this is
the office that we worked in in Basel
where we were doing the design for the
competition and this is one of my guys
Burkhardt Maya as a German engineer
standing next to a mock-up that we did
right outside so we had to walk past it
every day and just get some idea of the
scale of structure that we were dealing
with the span is about a thousand feet
for this structure so it's and it's a
highly seismic zone so it's a long way
and I thought that explained how the
building works because you know I can
remember being there at the early stages
and saying the scale of this thing is so
big we have to make the structure simple
and we really did and I mean you know
quite often I say that to people and
they say that can't be true but it is so
we took well basically what we do is we
took a series of columns around the
building and you can see they're each
the columns are each in pairs and then
we simply did Drew a tangent this is the
inner curve that that's around the
Athletics track we drew a tangent to the
curve and we did so that one would go
across there and then across there and
this one would go across there and then
across there and we did it like this so
you know there you can see all the
tangents to the curve you can see how it
works this is just a massive portal
frame I mean it's big but it's but it's
a bottle frame so to analyze it
structurally is really simple you know
you simply got you've got a bending
moment at this corner here you know
you've got a bending moment reverses in
the middle and we put a pin at the
bottom and it's just a portal frame and
they go in two directions because it was
complicated enough when you start adding
on the structure you know the the the
basically the cladding these this is the
because you'll you'll like this this is
just them for the support for the
cladding system basically so you can if
I go back you can see there's the bra
structure and then all we're doing is
because we've got these holes that are
different sizes you know just keep your
eye on something like that one there and
then you start to see how it's filled in
and by keeping the members the same size
I did the I was the engineer for the
Imperial War Museum which was over the
north which was Daniel Liebeskind first
building in the UK and I really like the
way he played with perspective and
tricking your eye and we were really
doing the same thing here by making the
outside size of these boxes all exactly
the same simply changing the wall
thickness depending on the stress that
you can't tell which is primary
secondary and tertiary structure so it
suddenly looks random
but it isn't just go back it's
incredibly regular so we turned a
regular structure into a random
structure you know just with a trick of
the eye so here's the project in
constriction I thought I'd run through a
few slides because you've probably never
seen this the Chinese government kept
this pretty under wraps you won't see
any construction shot so you can see the
columns are up there we looked at a
construction method we designed this
parametrically so our geometry Bowl
geometry and structural design were
linked completely every time we change
the geometry we got a new way of steel
out of the project and he did have a
retractable roof in the competition
stage which the Chinese government
scrapped for reasons when they had their
collapse in China you remember there
they had the well those the collapse of
the airport in in Charles de Gaulle in
Paris and they had an architect who was
working on a project in China they did a
complete review of all the projects and
on ours they decided to save some money
we'd already received approval and we
simply had
our project budget cuts effectively or
or maybe are overrun dragged back a
little bit I know who knows what it
costs so you can see a concrete ball
pretty simple concrete Bowl hairy Google
wanted to make all of the columns that
support the bowl
not vertical nothing could be vertical
and now honestly I was in that meeting
when we when he asked that and I said
what the hell it's complicated enough
let's just make no columns vertical you
know we could it was bad enough as it
was or how could it be worse and it's
worked out it worked out sort of fine we
set some rules and that worked out fine
now you see you know get some sense of
scale of how big this thing is
you know get a crane there then the you
know the buildings around the side so
this is constriction with the starting
to put the roof pieces up inside this
this inner ring was built on the ground
and then strand jacked up in yeah up
into place and held in place and then
the columns are on the outside and then
the beams are put in to connect the two
so you can see this is almost relishing
that staging it was supporting that in a
ring at the time taking on somebody's
phone on a site visit and quietly
we got a few kept getting photographs
like this some more shots on the outside
of the building at some idea of this
sort of crane each and sort of
complexity of the project and then it
starts taking shape you get up sort of
close and personal and see the structure
it's a double thickness structure this
is the outside and there's an inside
structure about forty five feet deep
it's something like that spanning a
thousand feet span to depth ratio 2223
something like that
so not outrageous you know it's in the
right order of magnitude of things you
can see it next to the Water Cube and
get some idea of the pollution in the
Beijing sky at the time and then more
hero shots of what it looked like later
on in the constriction and nice
reflection of the water nearby the
stairs the way you get up the building
it's complete it's not clad so that you
can see the support the strip to the the
cladding is the the envelope is really
just there that's ETFE single skin
stretched fabric there you can see that
piece is filled in that's finished and
you can see it over there so and then
you can see the inner
here protecting the seats inside on the
bottom layer of structure between the
two of these staircases that sort of
zigzag up the building so most people go
up and down the building in between the
structure on these staircases so
Manchester had those ramps on the
outside Beijing has these stairs between
the structure so again some idea of
census scale they had seven thousand
welders trained to do they did seven
hundred kilometres of weld on site on
this project just think about that after
this five seven hundred kilometres of
weld so once that four point three miles
or something a full strength wealth all
tested again I think it's the same shot
I showed you before guys doing the
planting and get some sort of sense of
you know difference in technologies you
can see the cladding very clearly and
the extent to which it goes around the
stadium there and then there were all
sorts of things I've got an ashtray I
don't smoke but it's a bird's nest
ashtray that I bought during the
Olympics and then these are the light
fittings that were done and it's one of
the ideas in the original brief they
said we want an iconic stadium and we
spent so much time wondering what iconic
was but basically we said it's if you
see the building you immediately
recognize where it is it's immediately
associated with that place so we said
you know the English red telephone box
is iconic it doesn't have to be big just
has to be instantly recognizable and now
this is all over Beijing if you go in
you know that this project is instantly
recognizable therefore we think its
iconic you can light it really well you
know it's pretty it sort of looks pretty
cool in various formats they're
incredibly proud of it this was the
topping out ceremony if you've ever been
to a topping out usually when a building
gets to the highest point you know they
have a party to celebrate reaching the
highest point usually there's about 50
or 100 people there this is the Chinese
version you know the during the Olympics
this is how the space worked around the
building and you know it was incredibly
efficient I've been to a number of these
major events this this was interesting
this was off the this was the
South China Morning Post newspaper in
Hong Kong these children were asked to
make think there four or five years old
they were asked to make a model of a
building out of old newspaper that they
were really proud of and they made the
birds in a stadium and they were but
they got they won first prize and there
on the front page in the newspaper so I
just like showing that because I'm
really so I think they did a great job
doing it the opening ceremony and
closing ceremony for the Olympics you
know is a incredibly dramatic and I was
really interested in how they managed to
weave in the sort of the stadium itself
into the show as part of the opening
ceremony of the game so pretty amazing
couple just I'm going to finish with it
just a few slides now bill Baker talked
about he when he was showing the end of
his Burj Khalifa show he showed this and
he said look what people are doing
that's one of my projects so this was
Dubai towers in Beijing one of the
projects that was cancelled but I show I
show it for a number of reasons that you
know it's pretty complicated
geometrically and you can see how tall
it is these are you know world's tallest
buildings and here's the Burj and it's
not as big as that but this is 550
meters tall about 1,700 feet pretty
pretty tall building and and we did a
lot of analysis on this building to make
it work what we found was what was
really interesting is that here's the
design sort of basically and there are
very few buildings in the world tall
buildings that are unstable under
gravity and we found that by actually
getting this building and leaning it
further back making it look even Wilder
it was more stable so we were able to
analyze this building in ways that we
could never have done before the
computer power that was available to us
at the time we did this and really the
wildness of this shape was really only
given by getting an elevator to go up
the tall spill and so it come up here
and it touches that side there and has
to get up to this level here or
something and and that was really as
wild as it got but it was designed
around that that elevator and it was
funny whenever I was doing this project
you know it's one of the you do these
jobs and they come to you in your dreams
and I was walking along one day through
a parking lot and I saw this it was just
a piece of sculpture
like around health like and I couldn't
believe it it looked almost exactly like
what we were designing it 1700 feet so I
had to take your photograph of it Apple
Campus I'm not sure if these slides are
public knowledge so you'll have to block
them from your memory as soon as you've
seen them but you know the idea is the
it's a foster project this is the
parking structure this is the energy
center this is the building that's got
all the press that Steve Jobs talked so
much about and the idea is that you know
it's a glazed building circular building
glazed entirely these are huge glass
panels and therefore it requires some
shading and this is the device this is
the level of detail in design that we
were going to to really try and figure
out how to bring air into the spaces so
the building with you know was was
really designed to the end detail the
the the idea is that it's back to those
1960s slides I showed precast concrete
these are the pieces for the feather for
it so we were sort of designing the
building then taking it apart figuring
out where all the pieces were figuring
out how they go together so these are
the sort of things that used to get in
Airfix model kits and things like that
so we're producing these for the
contractor with sequencing diagrams of
how to build a building so these are
videos they're the means and methods of
putting the building together it's a
base isolated building because it's
seismic so may ways in which you can put
the structure together with the systems
efficiently as envisaged by the designer
because one of the things that were lost
between the pyramids and today is that
the designers don't explain how they
envisaged a building being built today
and they should because we have to
envisage how it's built when we design
it but we don't communicate it but now
we can't because we have the tools in
which we can do that I've sort of like
this this is Banksy Banksy did this
iPhone is a prison you know there's a
prison buildings is the courtyard it
keeps people outside and this idea that
you're permanently connected to your
iPhone you never escape
from work and III and I saw this Banksy
thing and then when mm-hmm but if I if
you associated those two things that's
purely in your own mind that's nothing
didn't come from me but these people
work very you know this building is
24-hour building so it just made me
think of it the same thing so finally
what have I learned in my time as an
engineer so yeah out of all these
projects I believe these are fundamental
things that trial and error always
exceeds succeeds over lone genius
there isn't an architect I've ever
worked with who's so brilliant that the
idea is just got to be delivered you
there's always it's teamwork and trying
things out and coming up with ideas and
bouncing things around absolutely vital
to get a great building wild ideas you
know balloons are rubes crazy but just
encourage them it's rather those wild
ideas you get amazing solute solutions
you've got to fail off and just succeed
so it doesn't matter if you get things
wrong but you have to fail otherwise
you're not pushing the envelope ever
that there isn't a hierarchy and a
design team that everybody should be
equal
and has an equal say and and it works
really well so this idea of a pyramid or
hierarchy I don't think that's the way
in which it works and when you do
something gray it's just so addictive to
doing something next great but you just
want to do it again so celebrate success
always I think the design process
doesn't look like any of those earlier
diagrams design process looks like this
I was actually in a interview with Nick
Grimshaw and the client said to him how
are you going to get from A to B Nick
and he only got a shirt flipchart he
drew a line he said you think it's gonna
be like this and it's gonna be like this
and I and he tried to do it more well
maybe drew something like that but I
think it's sort of like this
but anyway it's definitely not like that
so you know design process is not linear
that you know if you challenge
conventional wisdom and I just think
this is genius but somebody taking a
prosthetic limit you know to now $1,000
a tie
and turning it into some that cost $8
and does the same job that's the level
of innovation that we want to see in the
building industry no no you know get it
down to $1,200 and if we have to have a
change in mentality to move the building
industry forward and we can now if you
design you know design sustainability
for me the only bit of it that matters
is sustained I mean if you make
something last longer like a pyramid
then it's just got to be it's got to be
sustainable right its carbon footprint
over time is zero or nearly zero so if
you can make buildings that you love for
that last long time then isn't it more
sustainable so you know maybe left
sticky stuff and maybe better quality
building and maybe materials that behave
similar mele and things will last longer
and crack less and and perform better
and and I believe it's possible if we
think about things differently I also
think this is going to happen that
currently we designed spaces like this
the one that we're in for a temperature
range and then you guys all have to
adapt to the space you know some people
got coats on some people have just got
shirts on so you have to change to super
space I think it's gonna this this is
people this is the temperature this is
people in the space and these are the
temperatures at which they're
comfortable everybody's different when
you get hot it's your hands and your
head that get hot and when you get cold
it's your hands and your feet that get
cold so spaces will adapt to you we're
gonna see a complete difference to
designing the entire volumes at constant
temperatures in the future because we
can the build just like the the planet
Earth we can adapt it to ourselves we
will find that we can adapt the building
to ourselves and if you think about that
you will understand there's many ways in
which you could you could do that and
get better and more effective and less
energy intensive building performance
the psychology of building use will be
cut will come into the design process
through data I think now the impossible
you know started by saying engineering
the impossible I think the impossible is
possible the two big points
to me are you know we're now in a period
where we control the future of this
planet let's be let's do that well and
that technology is connecting our brain
both sides of our brain together like
never been possible before and so that's
why I I submit that it is the greatest
time in history to be an engineer
that's it who's designed a building for
anybody other than the richest 1%
yeah you think so not sure
buildings are for the other 99% I think
well over half our our portfolio well
that's great that's great that's in
commercial certainly in commercial firms
that's not true it's the richest one
person
well TV current status of education for
engineers particularly for construction
and building well I mean there's two
sides of that question so are the
schools producing people who are capable
of doing projects under the current
process and regime yes so I would say
that in our business we are building
engineers the business up I'm
responsible for our building engineers
and I think the graduates would get in
there absolutely fantastic
well what I would say is that I don't
think that we're bringing them into an
environment where they can deliver their
potential I think we have the industry
has to change because we're getting
people who are coming out with ideas
that the industry isn't ready for and
there's got to be some some change and
we're seeing that change so if you look
at current construction conferences for
example you'll see they're around
integrated project delivery p3 different
forms that design a build contract what
are those things they're integrated
projects where they're really trying to
get back to that idea of whatever the
modern version of one mind is and and so
I think the industry is changing and
we're watching it in front of our eyes
we're seeing people try you know what
Forest City have been trying in Brooklyn
you need to build building modular
buildings at huge scale you know you you
see wooden skyscrapers and the patek you
know what would on the potential of
those buildings there's lots of
innovation going on but it needs a
breakthrough and you know the you know
innovation you know this idea of yet
continuous improvement and then step
change I feel we're right on the verge
of step change and then I do think the
schools are producing talented people
who are very capable I don't think the
industry is allowing them to achieve
their potential so I don't think we need
a whole change in the in the
education process and engineers that
coming out of school are incredibly
talented I mean I wouldn't get a job if
I came out of school these days I'm
already can get through school that's
true
do you think that the legal profession
is a handicap to engineering creativity
for the future yeah I do and I actually
when I did this you know I I put way too
many slides you know I had twice as many
as this row right when I started and
because I can't help you I don't and
some of the slides I had I was showing
and it's not just the legal profession
it's the it's the brokerage you know the
real it that the the people who who who
lease out the spaces because we have a
structural engineers we have to design
for load so there are a least double
what that building will ever experience
in its entire life and so you know a lot
of the innovations that being made are
then being completely counteracted by
you know tenants wants 100 pounds per
square foot capability in this space
they don't they couldn't possibly get a
hundred pounds a square foot in that
space there wouldn't be any room to move
and I mean if the pilot would filing
cabinets they don't have any more fun in
cabinets anymore it's all computers but
so that does that and then there's that
there's the legal profession which you
know haven't really struggling to get
around their heads around the fact that
we could transfer a model to a builder
and not take on liability that we won't
have if we put it on the 2d piece of
paper and pass it over to them because
there's data in that model that we are
not guaranteeing and I just don't think
I just imagine if we didn't have to pass
it over we were all one we'd all be
working on on some version of a common
data model and and it's really the
lawyers that are stopping us doing that
and and you know more fool us if we
accept that limitation you know we've
got a as an industry we've got to say
this is what we do and we're going to
you know we can do it better and and you
know III say the week
design buildings half the cost in half
the time if we really wanted to and just
imagine you know what a difference that
would be with a growing population and
an urbanization just imagine how much
beneficial to the economy that would be
and you know that's my dream and I think
it's possible in my working lifetime
thank you for the talk I had two
questions for you the first year your
title is a kind of agitprop for
architects this is the greatest time for
the arket for the engineer which could
have a message for the architect but
also reminds me of engineering and let's
say the late 70s which is also a very
optimistic time but and it has to do
with something a scale that I didn't see
here today which would be as a much
larger scale than the building itself we
saw mostly kind of the ark architectural
scale today but what about kind of the
engineer today and the macro project the
infrastructural the city as an
engineering project the second question
why did you end with this slide anyway
because I believe in freedom of speech
and I want to be supportive of what
happened and I I feel strongly about it
and and it emotionally affects me and
and I just wanted to win and with it
that's it's important to me and I'm
making a statement where I stand on it
to answer you to answer your first
question in in terms of City so where I
think about cities as they're like a
living organism that we can never do one
of the things that bothered me a little
bit Internet and I know we're doing it
it's like a research project we've got
to take steps to get to a solution but
this idea of net zero energy buildings
or living buildings or buildings that
give back to you know let's just talk
about any energy for a moment it's
really not the way to go because if you
can plug that building into a city
ecosystem and so that it gives and takes
just like an organism does you know
you've got to create that circle
that the waste product from one thing is
the feed product for something else and
we can if we if we design buildings as
part of a city rather than you know
quite often were given a site and things
come to that boundary and then get taken
away from that boundary and we think
about it like that if we can think
bigger we can solve the problem much
better oh yes I do and I see you know I
I worked at AE come for two years and a
comm have all the reason I went there
was because they have all of these
skills within the firm and I believe
that they were the only company today in
that position where they could actually
do that
I don't think organizationally that
they're at that point that they have the
potential to do that and it's about
working together so you've got to have
you know transport planners and and you
know botanists and psychologists and
engineers and architects and landscape
architects working together on a common
framework and I thinks it for me city
plans I'm all you know I go to in San
Francisco we have spur and I would go
along a lot regularly and I'm always
sort of you know at the end of our I go
away feeling yeah you know it's it looks
at a at a block or a region or a heights
of buildings and I think it just isn't
going deep enough to really address the
problem of what this what will San
Francisco look like in 2050 you know
we've got to address completely
different problems for the ones that
would be interested in the plans so
they're just not complete enough they're
really looking more often at the more at
the aesthetic and and you know sometimes
how people use spaces or spaces between
buildings then how they really function
and work and there's something missing
but there's lots of people working at it
you know all these like you know cisco
connected cities and again there's lots
of people who they know they know where
the answer is the question is how do we
get there and I think you know you you
only get to a destination we don't have
to identify a destination before you can
plan your journey and I think the
destination is known it's really about
the journey now it's only a matter of
time
but a bit ability that interconnection
is absolutely vital
thank you you saved me
it's all about the journey okay